[Music]
happy Thursday everybody welcome back to
the data science hangout if this is your
first time joining us here today it is
very nice to meet you and thanks for
spending your Thursday with us if we
haven't met I'm Rachel I host the data
science hangout of course uh and also
lead customer marketing at posit
this is our open space to chat about
data Science Leadership questions you're
facing and getting to hear about what's
going on in the worlds of data across
different Industries so we're here every
Thursday at the same time same place so
if you're watching this recording on
YouTube later the link to add it to your
calendar and join us live here will be
in the details
below um I'll also put a a link in the
chat just a little like short link if if
you ever want to share the hangout with
friends
too but together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everyone and we love to hear from
everybody no matter your years of
experience titles industry or even
languages that you work in um and so
every week at the hangout I'm joined by
different leader from the community who
joins us to share their experience and
answer questions from you all so if
you're here for the first time let me
just give you a little rundown of how
this works um it is totally okay to just
listen in here but there's also three
ways that you could jump in and ask
questions or provide your own
perspective on certain topics too so you
can jump in by raising your hand on zoom
and I'll I'll monitor that uh you could
put questions in the zoom chat and just
put a little star next to it if it's
something you want me to read out loud
instead if you're maybe in a a coffee
shop or something and then then third we
have a slid link which Hannah just
shared right when I said that thank you
where you can ask questions anonymously
as well with all that thank you so much
for joining us here this Thursday I am
so excited to be joined by my co-host
Ari sigard KN International lead
programmer statistical programing
programming specialist at Novo noris and
Ari I would love to have you introduce
yourself and maybe pronounce your name
better than I did and share a little bit
about um the work that you do but also
something you like to do outside of work
too definitely I I think you did it
pretty well um we used to say knoff as
my last name but that's probably because
we're from yeah in
Scandinavia um yeah as you said I mean
I'm an international lead programmer at
Nordisk and um that means that I'm like
the responsible programmer for all of
our programming deliverables on clinical
trials I'm responsible for um um writing
out documents for the authorities and
interact with them whenever we have
actions and um in the end uh the primary
responsible for our data packages and
code that goes to
authorities
um and then yeah outside of work I
really love spending time with my wife
and kids I have two sons um friends and
family as well my oldest son recently
picked up golfing and he's only five and
a half but I used to play when I was
younger and so we've been spending a lot
of good times on the Range already
um um and I really like to play a lot of
guitar as well so yeah that's my what my
time goes with that's awesome well thank
you it sounds like your son's going to
be a superstar it's already starting
five we'll see we'll see he loves it so
that's the most important thing yeah
that's great well I get to start off
with the the questions here as we wait
for everybody to to start jumping in um
but I know in a few weeks you're going
to give a a presentation here at posit
too and you've reach an incredible NDA
uh Milestone C could you explain a
little bit about what that means and
what you're going to be talking about in
a few
weeks yeah so I mean what's really
special about this is um like in the
past few years whenever we've been at
conferences um we've heard so much more
about our like emerging within Pharma
and people are um starting to use it
more in these GXP controlled
environments um and we've been working
towards um setting up a GP uh approved
environment and really and sorry I used
an acronym at first because I forgot as
I was saying it what the actual length
was but if we use acronyms do you mind
just explaining what they are too of
course okay cool thank you yeah yeah
somebody WR wrote in the chat so MDA is
a new drug application um
to to the American authorities food and
Dr I mean it's it's very hard in Farmer
because there are so many abbreviations
so it's very hard to to to continue
talking about subject without mentioning
some of them um but I'll do my best to
um to we'll try and do it in the chat
too it looks like Mike's ready to hang
out with and uh put acronyms in there
yeah no so so what's really especially
about this Milestone is um is we've
primarily used um proprietary language
to do most of our programming within
Pharma um and in recent years uh people
have been opening much more up to to
using open source languages um but that
comes with a lot of challenges when you
need to use it in a heavily regulated
environment such as Pharm is because
there are um a lot of rules and
standards you need to squeeze down on
top of your processes in order to comply
with with um all the regulatory
authorities not only in the US but
around the world so there a lot of
Demands to how we actually uh produce
code and submit code and data to
authorities uh so we've been working on
it
for like we started like almost seven
years ago just like U trying to do
something with with r um and that has
really grown into now having a uh an NDA
submission where we have um tables
figures and listings done in our uh we
have some analysis data sets done in our
uh we have packages we have submitted
and so on so um really the the full
monty of of of doing this and the reason
why it's so special is and the number
one question at least I've heard when
we've been at conferences is whether
anybody has done it
before and and the predecessor to what
we've done is really uh the work from
the our Consortium working group there
is one for ARA submission where um FDA
also has played a huge role in in kind
of giving input to what's possible with
the submitting
this um packages and and AR code to to
the authority so uh so uh for us it's
really special that at least now we have
an answer that we know that we have done
it and hopefully others will do it soon
in the future as well that's great and I
was putting my clapping Emoji in here
but thank you for for sharing that story
in a few weeks too so I know when you
you were sharing a little bit about what
you do outside of work you mentioned
that you're a musician and play guitar
as well and I see Libby called this out
in the chat too we have so many
different musicians in the data space
especially in this hangout room here and
I was wondering like how is that carried
over for you into your data work or do
you think that it it plays a part I
think I mean so I'm a I'm a
selftaught musician so um I mean I
learned it off of YouTube like U when
YouTube was like brand new almost I
spent so much time learning stuff off of
YouTube and it's actually the same with
most of my R skills today I mean I I
studied mathematics at the University
but it was like the chalk and chalkboard
type of mathematics we weren't doing
that much programming until the end but
so I I think a lot of the skills that I
learned today especially around R comes
from both like what the community is
putting out there in terms of just like
educational material but there are so
many people putting stuff up on on
YouTube to to learn from um and then
there's also like I mean when you play
music with people you're kind of in sync
with them and and
um
and not to make like a Cheesy analogy
but I mean when when you're developing
code with people I remember uh seeing
this almost a meme right about like a a
get commit history looking like a Guitar
Hero track um because there's just so
many yeah ranching and so on
so so
um I think there is like some great
opportunities to like co-create uh stuff
with people both in in in music and in
the code yeah that's great how do you
actually collaborate with your
colleagues and code so uh it's not that
long ago that we at least where I work
uh
moved into using Version Control for
most of what we do even though we have
been doing statistics and programming
for quite a while moving an entire
organization into learning git and and
working with
repository um it's been quite a
challenge but um I think we've been
quite successful in like lowering the
barrier so wrapping a lot of stuff up uh
um into other functions such that you
don't need to think about like how to
set up a repo so we primarily use a a
Dews for it how do I set up a repo how
do I set up a pipeline how do I make
sure that I have the Upstream set and
how do I so all these things you're more
I mean people
can um it's very easy to get your head
around like commit uh Push Pull like
those three commands everything like
outside of that is is a little bit more
advanced um so so we use that here and
then externally I mean now also laboring
more with people through farme where we
use GitHub and also keep propos s for
that yeah some I see Jeff I think you
had a followup question on this do you
want to jump in here I think the
question
is how do you do devops with GitHub
actions and docker and Jeff feel free to
jump in if you want to add more context
or you're just chiming
in so I mean we we um when we were
testing out for like which product to
use I mean we we first tested out gitlab
um but we found we had much more freedom
in um in asops also because we wanted to
to try and do um like some of our
project organization a little bit
differently uh like the way we we
organize um programs and who should do
it and how are we discussing about these
things um and GitHub don't have to the
same extent this project organizations
they do have canand boards but they
don't have the same level
of um interactivity with work items and
what you can do in terms of like
manipulating them with pipelines and and
apis and so on so
so and also I mean we're noo is a major
comp customer at Microsoft so so it was
kind of right down our ballpark to go to
to that product but um so we don't use
GitHub actions unfortunately we we uh we
use as and and write a lot of yaml files
with the pipelines and and best
scripting and so on Ari I was thinking
maybe in the beginning here it would be
helpful for some of us who don't come
from a a Pharma background to just
understand a little bit more about like
a specific use case or or walk us
through a project that your team might
work on yeah so um I sit in the
biostatistics department so that's
really like the evidence generating
Department of uh of the drug development
cycle so um we help uh run clinical
trials so we uh have like uh the the
people in the chain right before us is
like data management they uh set up all
the systems to collect data and then we
get the data in bi statistics and not
too long ago um a lot of Standards data
standards were rolled out uh called cisk
and I'm sorry I can't really it's a very
long acronym for something that's okay
yeah but it's it's a data standard for
for like collected data and Analysis
data so um and we create these data sets
it could be based off lab data it could
be like vital science data it could be
some specific measurements depending on
the disease area that you're working in
and and and this is where we I mean use
R we use sess for it as well uh we run
the trials um
in in G repos uh and um and on top of
this I mean what we're trying to do now
is is
um like build tables and figures with
our um but also uh now shiny
applications on top of that like some of
the first selling points for us to
really get or into the organization was
um creting Shin apps uh so we had uh a
very tedious process of like reviewing
pharmacokinetic data uh where people
were like entering meetings with like a
100 pager PDF document with like phac
kinetic curves and like they had all
reviewed
them before the meeting written comments
and then you would like go through
everything and had like modeling outputs
and it just seemed like an obvious use
case for us to to to go into a shiny app
and and that was one of the first thing
that we really like sell to the to our
stakeholders
um um you know so we we do parly do that
but like our bread and butter is
creating these data sets it's doing
statistical analysis it's doing um
summary statistics descriptive
statistics of adverse events and uh like
lab results and so on
um and then at the end we wrap all of
these things up um into like a
submission dosier where we have a
medical writers who write up documents
send it to authorities and now uh there
are at least three Health authorities
around the world who required that we
send our data and our code to produce
both the data some tables and
figures cool thank you so did you
basically say to them hey you don't have
to go through this 100 page document
here's this app yeah yeah I mean basic
so there we we like when you always have
a project like like when you have a
project like that you always like tend
to maybe go you want to do too much in
the beginning like you want to automate
like we want to have automatic minutes
based off like the comments that people
were doing and and essentially
yeah I mean in the beginning it was just
like you don't have to look at it in PDF
like we're also saving two here right
and and and you can look at it in the
screen and then we'll kind of build out
the the modules around communicating in
the app seeing what other people have
done and so on cool thank you Travis I
see you had a question in the chat a bit
earlier you want to jump in sure um so I
know Nova's been working on this open
study Builder solution um which is more
focused on um data capture for those not
in Pharma it be like electronic data
capture so EDC systems is the front end
that faces clinicians or their research
assistants or whomever is entering data
and these are dominated by um a couple
of giant and
um I'll just say like let's say Legacy
um looking uh software providers and so
this open study Builder looks really
interesting
um but it's very much kind of new forj
and and kind of like in the Weeds on
that side wondering what the connection
to to your side of the house looks like
um on the biostat side are they plugging
into R do you have good apis or is that
kind of future State yeah so um just to
give a little bit of History to that so
we have had a a system for metad data
management for quite some years so
whenever we start of a trial like we put
a we built the entire trial design with
all of the lab rounders and all the
visors and so on and that really builds
like a metadata infrastructure for when
we need to run the trials we also put in
um like metadata to use in the actual
outputs tables and figures and so on and
we found like that works really well
when you're just like developing our
small part in BIO statistics what we
really want to do is um let's say I have
metad data about some parameter
definition
uh and they're writing up a protocol uh
where they want to use that parameter um
it the open study build will kind of be
like the one one source of Truth for
everything that's kind of connected to
to data in some way or another um and
that's why they also buil it on on top
of this graph technology from from new
4G um so what we will use it for is um
like U writing protocols uh where you
have like topic based um
um text that you just pull out um it's
to build a much more coherent and made
it metadata driven um like full pipeline
around the bio statistics and the
deliverables we we do um so we've been
using meta data for many years um but
like
um we want to reuse a lot of that
information in the documents that we
write uh such that because a lot of
projects today are kind of making up
their a lot not making up their own but
they're they're slightly changing up
definition of things when they write it
in protocols or like data review guide
or whatever it is that we're handing
over to authorities so it's to build a
system to to manage all that and for us
yeah it will be API calls internally we
have
um like the same way we have like a
Master model of our metad data for uh
like for instance stdm uh study data and
and Analysis data uh we also have a
Master model of like all the meta data
data sets that go into producing both
those data sets but also tables figures
and listings so
um I mean we're biding really hard on
having like a fully metadata driven
pipeline uh to to the extent possible
that we think you thank you I'm gonna
jump over to a few of the anonymous
questions too and one was um could Ari
share a bit about how he got into the
Pharma industry um yeah so as I said I
mean my background was in in mathematics
I was doing a topology and like High
dimensional
geometry uh and like at some
point during like the Master's part of
my education I was thinking like who who
needs this out in the real world um so I
kind of shifted towards doing more like
statistic stuff uh doing more
programming um and I kind of learned
that high dimensional geometry is not
that different from like n dimensional
feature spaces
got really caught up in learning about
machine learning and and I did my master
thesis in um like prediction modeling on
MRI data so I was really intrigued by
like that intersection between like
medicine uh and and Technology like what
could you do uh in that field um so I
was looking
for for places where I could explore
that more at that time seens were like
the one creating all the MRI machines
um but there's I don't think there's SE
here in in Denmark where where I live um
uh so and I ended up applying for a a
job at NOA at that time um and uh so I
started here straight out of University
and uh haven't Liv since I say
that's great thank
you um okay let's see I'll jump over to
Mike I saw you asked a question earlier
in the chat you want to jump in here
next need to remind myself what the
question was apologies um so I saw a
really interesting um presentation from
Nova Nordisk about the you know there's
essentially a Pharma verse of our
packages that you're using um and you
you have packages for everything
basically which is amazing so
um are those packages developed like
from from scratch within Novo or those
kind of Novo rappers around other things
so um they are primarily rappers around
um like terse stuff uh because there are
internal standards to pretty much
anything you could think of that there
is a standard for so um and some of them
are to um to make it possible to work
with are within our environment like the
way we store data the way we export
things um and I said like utility
functions to work with aops to work with
G to work with um to all these different
systems um that we have
internally some of
them uh can you still hear me all
right yes I think it froze for a second
on my end but I can hear I could hear
you the whole time okay
um so some of it um uh is like a
layering on top of these Med dat to do
things um smarter uh some of it is uh
building like a package for creating
tables that are specific to the the no
way of styling tables and so on so um
but but one thing that kind of
has kind of catched up to us is um
they were developed
without uh like looking too much uh to
the open source world so now when we
actually want to do more with u with
Farmers where multiple companies are are
working it's really hard to separate
like the noo part uh and like the real
functionality of of the package so so
we're working on that night now it it's
an interesting design issue then you
know because
it I can understand that building
rappers on existing things to tailor it
for your needs is a really neat way of
doing things but as you say it kind of
then locks you into a particular way of
working that maybe you know has problems
down the line so they're probably pros
and cons right exactly um and we do and
and I mean there's also like in in
recent years so many companies have
opened up much more to talk about how
they're actually solving things and
we're also doing that as well and we
really want to contribute to kind of
keeping those lines open um so we we're
definitely trying to to Pivot some of
our packages either kind of committing
to some of the open source packages that
are there or or pivoting our packages
and kind of see if they can get into the
open source well Amanda I see you raised
your hand do you want to jump in
here hi yeah um so I'm a little bit
curious about the transition um Nova
nordis made um are I guess there's two
parts to this question the first is you
know during that uh trying to prove that
you know the phe or using arm was just
as good as SAS programming uh how did
did you have like you know I know
there's always a second reader on the
data so did you have one person using
our and the other person using SAS or
how did that go and then the other
question I have is
um you know I've seen some reports of
the RN SAS data coming back just
slightly different nothing that would
change a decision or anything but just
slightly different um so how how do you
sort of address that as your like sort
of mid transition here I mean uh to
speak to your first uh question so um
our primary goal has not been to like
replace cess with r i mean we we are
really aiming for a much more like
language agnostic world where
programmers use the language that
they're most comfortable with um in
terms of like getting it into the
organization and and having people using
it um we started out like what we really
wanted to prove was that it was possible
to like make a real
deliverable uh with r where we make the
tables and figures in R um so so there
we did the the actual deliverable in R
and we did the the the parallel
programming in SS to make sure that that
that it is that as what we would expect
to get in in SS as well and then down
the line I mean I I remember seeing um
one of my good peers Michael rimler from
GSK talking about their uh program
called R for validation where they were
really rolling out that everybody was
allowed to use R for
for validation and um I think like
building on top of that we thought that
well I mean they're already using it for
validation so why not try to use it in
in production uh like on a very small
scale um and now today we have I mean
all kinds of U mixtures of how people
are approaching it uh whether they're
doing the primary program in CS and R is
[Music]
um is not that important anymore because
we kind of built up an environment that
supports like a multilingual
execution um and now I can R your second
question can you repeat that again um
mostly about how you know because there
are small differences in the numerical
Al you know like how does that address
yeah so
um I mean so we ECT that there is a
difference so and and in many of the
like compare packages that's out there
you can set a criteria on on how um to
which decimal places shot the the
numbers at line uh and there's always
like when you're storing a floating
point inur they will always be like a
small difference even with like the same
number within the same system
and I think what we have really been
preaching internally is that we really
try to to uh to cre like conclusions
over numbers so so of course if you see
something that's totally off like you're
you're going to investigate what's
happened there but that that when we use
and and kind of set these two systems up
against each other are we still looking
at at the same conclusions for um these
Adverse Events or this lab parameter and
so on and that's been our kind of take
on it thank
you um Jared I see you had asked a
question uh one was had a star so maybe
I'll start reading and if you want to
jump in I'll look to see if you unmute
um but Jared said definitely interested
in knowing more about how you pitched um
to your upper management to use shiny
apps and Jared said mainly I get pushed
back because of valid validation
concerns on doing that versus the
standard 200 Page PDF
files yeah
um I
think uh I would say luckily um our
management have been very open to to
like it's almost expected that you try
and solve uh problems in a new way and
that's kind of what we've been
been raised with here at least I've been
raised with it here um so of course
there are a lot of technical aspects
around that but we we kind of did the
the same thing that you would do with
maybe another Innovation product is that
you would talk with the people who were
supposed to use it and and like it most
of them said that it was a really good
idea and then we said to our manager
like everybody thinks this is a great
idea right and and and uh and we think
we have the skills to build it and and
and of course like one good thing is
it's always good to apply a little bit
action on an idea before you you you go
searching for opinions because opinions
can quickly kind of hold you back but
and we had already applied some actions
like buil something around it um and so
you you're kind of coming up with
something that they almost uh at least
we trying to get into a scenario where
they can't say no um or at least that
like can we test this out on one or two
trials
um and then you make sure that uh like
all of the downstream processes around
this I mean we're still like in
compliance with standards we're still
like able to deliver everything we're
supposed to do and and U now hopefully
people would be a lot happier and now
also like CO2 right we really want to
save some trees as well
um um so that's been a major uh selling
point for us in terms of of shiny apps
um and then
also another thing that I think most
companies say today is that they really
want to be data driven right and if you
want to hold people to the word I think
like our community is probably one of
the the the parts of the organization
that have like the most enabling power
to give to other people who doesn't
necessarily have um data Sciences skills
and I think that's like if you can make
somebody higher up in the organization
realize that you can make so many people
do their job in a much more simple way
just by going uh into a shiny app or
maybe even just like looking at
automated reports on a connect server I
mean what be it that you can enable so
many people just by by by doing that so
um so yeah that's been our kind of
selling point of of trying to get all of
this into to our processes yeah love
that thank you h i see you had a
question in the chat want to jump in
here um hi yes so my background is in
mathematics and I'm now moving into
bioscience um
so I'm currently doing my PhD and I'm
going to finish in a couple years and
Industry just seems like this massive
unknown where as an academic I don't
really know what is wanted do you have
any advice for like things to learn or
Technologies to learn to make yourself
more competitive in that
environment and specifically in
bioscience sorry yeah I I think um I
mean now I can only really speak for my
own company I think um there are of
course like some technology is that
we're moving more towards I mean so if
you
know like any of the open source
languages like do you have
um I mean recently we when we have
candidates we also look I mean are they
on GitHub like have they done something
interesting do
they can they like display a passion for
what they're doing and for us now we're
also putting it in our job at that it's
it's almost more important that you are
like willing to learn new stuff um of
course there are some jobs also in the
farm industry where you have to have a
specific degree to do that job but but
for instance for development jobs we're
looking much more into that like U like
you have a passion for doing it we can
see that you have done it before and and
when we speak with you um you know your
way around
ER like for instance package development
and which packages you use to do uh
package development and um so I think
it's it's a much more now a display of
Interest so I think a lot of companies
today do these
um like uh interview um questions or
exercises that you do um before and and
like if you're applying at a
pharmaceutical company then like uh ask
about like the disease that you're maybe
if you gotten some data on on some uh
disease like what does this mean what
like show that you're interested
in in um in what it is that they are
trying to uh to do in in Pharma um but I
mean keeping up with with technology is
a is a is a really good thing to have on
your your recipe yeah thank
you um Rebecca I see you men you
mentioned you had a a niche question but
I feel like this could be a good
audience to throw that out there too so
you want to want to jump in here oh
you're super kind I wasn't gonna try to
bug the whole group but I in search of
someone who has any experience with Sasa
and our
interoperability um yeah anyway I it's
pretty Niche so if it doesn't exist but
in the conversation of uh the agnostic
Wild West I was curious if anyone has
that
experence um unfortunately we don't have
sire I did see that you also posted on
the which is great no no I think it's
great um I do know like some of the
other Danish pharmaceutical companies uh
use SVA um maybe I could try and get
somebody into to to that slack channel
to share if they have any experience
with that yeah I would love that I'm
coming from a mostly SAS forward
organization but as a currently 100% our
user and trying to help people who want
to use both as my use case um yeah yeah
since I think we've we've already carved
out the people who are willing willing
to already commit to 100% R I'm trying
to um help those who wna want to use
both so thank you enjoying this a lot
welcome I'm G to jump back to a
conversation about packages for a second
here I saw there was a slido question
that said I'm curious for mari's
experience of writing packages when
would it be considered Overkill to
create a package and when is it
Justified well I
mean ER it depends on whether so I mean
of course now I'm sitting in an
organization where you know that a lot
of people are doing the same exact thing
but maybe just a little bit different
than you are so most of the things that
we do every day is something that at
least 200 other people are doing uh so
and that's that's a really a strong rale
for just making a package around spe
working specifically with tables or G or
reos and so on
um so but if you're working for yourself
or in a small group um like my wife is
is a PhD student currently and and it's
also done like a small clinical trial
and you kind of quickly learn that you
can actually gain so much from like
setting up functions for yourself to
kind of repeat tasks over and over again
right to read in small data sets or to
format something that you want to Output
later on so um so I think there's
probably not a package too small if some
Body Benefits from it uh and especially
yourself but um in our case it's it's
pretty easy to know when you're supposed
to do a package most things uh um and
also kind referring to the comment
before most things end up in a package
because we expect that many people will
will use them yeah how are you actually
like helping share those packages across
the organization or like helping share
what other people are doing in different
teams so work doesn't I guess get
duplicated do you have Community groups
um yeah so one thing that was running
and I think it's still running is uh we
had this initiative called radar where
like everybody could post ideas um to
not just like code development but
process development or uh like let's get
new coffee in the coffee machine or like
whenever people starts the start they
should get a water bottle now and so all
these different things um in terms of
code development like moving into asops
is has been a way for us to also first
of all make like all of that work
visible so before like I couldn't
necessarily see the code and and
programs from another drug project
within NOA and we tried to really open
up and make all of that work visible and
kind of in a in a help yourself way
where like if I want to see what other
people are doing I can just now see all
of their code and it's the same way with
the package development now that like
all of that development and organization
of development is also available for
everybody to to see so um yeah so that's
that's the way we've done it yeah thank
you um George I see you had asked a
question a bit earlier about shiny do
you want to jump in and I think the
question was um do you see let me just
jump back I think it's do you see python
for shiny as something you would use for
your use case in the future or now I
think um there will probably so I'm I'm
not that V worst in in Python uh but I I
can see
um I mean there definitely will be some
use cases uh for python for us as well
but a lot of the stuff um like now we we
have like a huge SS infrastructure and
now we also build a huge R
infrastructure and now when we're
starting up with python I mean like you
have the reticulate package and you have
so much like interoperability between R
and python that there might be many
things um
that where you either use like the the
plumber API or reticulate to kind of use
the best thing of those languages so not
even if you were to at some point in the
future do a full trial in Python like
you would maybe just call some of the r
infrastructure underneath it because
those two languages are now so easily to
kind of switch between
um U but I I I love the quote I think
and probably I saw Joe Chen's keynote
again not too long ago about shiny I
think it was last year where he says
like python was the it's the second best
thing for
everything um and it is
really like when you're looking at doing
like production grade Enterprise level
um apps or systems that build both an R
shiny and also other Technologies I I
think that python will be some of the
things and and that's also what we like
recently hired for that we want to have
python developers also to influence some
of the stuff that we're doing in r that
might be even better to do in in Python
so it's it's definitely coming I would
say thank you um so a question that I
love to to get to ask leaders in this
space is could you share an important
lesson that you've learned over your
career or maybe a career lesson that
just stands out to you when I ask that I
think I mean there are kind of two
things that come to mind and and one of
them is I mean this is just my kind of
personal belief in in uh like if you
want to do new fun stuff that you think
will actually help somebody at work as
well is like I try to do this like rule
where I have no side projects like
because usually like you're doing work
and then you have this side project that
you're like really excited about like
you want to build up some stuff and so
on and and uh but people know that like
the actual work is really what consumes
all of your time so trying to to uh to
have no no side projects in the way
where as if you have a side project
you're trying I'm really trying hard to
make like this is actually what I'm
supposed to do right like the same with
this shiny app that we were trying to
like this is what this is how the
process should be this is how we want to
work with it um and also now like
rolling our like we wanted to do more
our development and and we can also see
now that like we can interface so many
different things that like
um but the people coming into like
especially my project like if I've told
them like now we're running these five
trials everything is in s and on the
side you'll have to learn R because in
two years time uh we're going to do a a
trial in R so I've really tried to use
my power in that sense that I really
wanted to change their environment such
that like it's not a side project
anymore like this is I want you to learn
this stuff like on the job and we'll try
our best to kind of support you in uh in
in doing that
because I mean there's also like some
like logical aspect of like working
towards a deadline with something you
know will be used by somebody so you you
you try a little harder um but it's also
just like whoa this is really new and
exciting and and there are people here
to help me do it and and people just
grow incredibly fast if you let their
side projects be their main projects
really um and another thing is like one
of the things
that like made the biggest splash in
terms of now we have like some new
technology we could use is like it it's
not the shiny apps and it's not like
using R and like other processes I I did
this uh so whenever we have a trial and
in and there might be some like
sensitive information or confidential
information that you need to keep secret
until you kind of do a press release
with
results um everybody who has access to
those data need to be um an inside list
and what we previously done is like the
responsible programmer so program my
role kind of tracks um who has access to
the data uh and then we like generate
list that we sent to like our legal
department and and they put them on
inside so it's like this long chain of
and they like up to like when we do the
the release and so on like they're
asking every day like maybe twice a day
um for this list like did anybody go off
this did anybody like new uh get access
to the data um and I remember I I don't
want to do that every day I don't want
to like sit and like figure out who has
access to the data um and luckily with
with r we now had like we could query
our
um the server that we have data on for
accesses and I just wrapped that into
like a data table in a markdown script
put it on a connect server and then just
made it open for them and made it
refresh itself every six
hours and like so many people uh who
like maybe have technical roles that are
not really touching data in that sense
like you have so many people now getting
automatically on The Insider list that
they may not have been on before and
there are so many people outside of the
area that I have and they were like
calling me like what is this thing that
I'm now on this in and and not because
they they they they wanted to like bad
about uh having access to the data but
but it just created such a huge splash
that now we were able to like automate
this part of it and so many people were
kind of affected by something that that
we have automated that like that has
really like resonated like far out into
the to to to our stakeholders that we
that we did that um and I mean we
thought it was pretty cool there so many
people now like automatically got on the
the list and that's been like one of the
biggest flashes to like we all automated
something right that that actually
created value for for others so so that
was pretty cool yeah love that it's it's
really cool when you you get to see all
of that feedback from everybody right
away like I just the yesterday I did
something really small where I added
like a download CSP to a table that was
in a Cordo do and I realized right away
like that made that report so much more
impactful to somebody that they could
download
it NE I I see you just put a question
here in the chat you want to jump in and
I can read it it is what is needed to
submit a shiny app to a regulatory
agency what are the requirements that
they are looking for um so I might not
be the best one to answer this one
because it's not something we have done
um the only thing I know is that the our
Consortium working group R for
submission have some really great people
working on getting uh shiny apps to
FDA and there are many aspects of that
like um how do you read the data into a
shin app in a system where you don't
know where the data is right how do you
set spin up something that can run a
shine yet there's been a um so there is
a an association
for statistical programers in Pharma
called fuse which has had a working
group around like interactivity and
submission for quite a few years where
they were talking about like if
everybody is submitting sh apps like FDA
will never know like there's no like red
thread around like this is how we do
data Imports in shines so if everybody
is making up their own uis about um how
you analyze data um I think FDA will
will have a hard time going through all
those ch so they've been working a
little bit on like should we try and set
up some standards around submitting
something like a shf to to FDA um and I
think
even like even list could even uh do it
like if you were doing just like HTML
file if you were using Flex dashboard to
do stuff um I think that could go a
really long way and I and I do believe
so ifda has a
a file format specification document
over all of the allowed files and I'm
pretty sure uh HTML is on that one so
you could get pretty far probably with h
with doing uh something in quto or or
markdown that way yeah so maybe a big
question to answer in a few minutes here
but I
see uh Jared you had a question on Val
validation if you want to jump in and
and ask that yeah I know this is just a
kind of a hot button topic that a lot of
groups are going into but uh just how
did you guys approach the issue of like
dual independent programming and
validating your atom sdtm atom tlf data
sets um was it more of a one side one
side usess another used r or if you both
used R when it came to like package and
environment versioning
like validation
to provide that full traceability to the
FDA like how did you guys approach that
infrastructure behind the scenes if you
don't mind me asking yeah um so one of
the things I think I can mention first
is that uh like for quite some years we
have been working with our standard
operating procedures and making them
like
um more easy to work under and
especially so we have one for we call it
the custom programming uh sop standard
operating procedure
um where we talk about like the
different Revenue levels that we're
applying to
to to custom programs as we call them
and and in there we we kind of
introduced a a self- REV level a p
review level and then uh double
programming rev
level most people people call it and and
we're actually trying to
do uh less and less double programming I
mean um so so so for many years we've
kind of been had our ears blown for of
uh risk-based approaches to many things
and
um H and so so we've been trying to like
you double program the really most
essential Parts primary analysis is the
most important analysis data sets um and
then if you kind of step one level out
to uh like most people do double
programming
uh they have done it in CES but most
people are doing it in R now we're also
doing like R versus R um and then in
terms of like doing those tfl in order
to encapsulate like what you're doing on
the trial I mean we're running um rnv or
Ren um to control like the local
environment and that's also why like we
we needed to have those
trials uh we needed to add them use GI
uh because we need to track like that
local
environment um and then if you step one
further out um into like how are we
getting packages into the
organization um I mean we uh use posit
package manager and we apply kind of the
risk based approach from the r
validation Hub to we do risk assessment
of
packages um and we have worked uh or
some of my very good colleagues have
worked very hard
on um like automate automating that to
some sense I think if you want to have a
really good example of um of how that
would look like is I think it's Aaron
Clark from B
uh has uh has created this risk
assessment app which is built upon the
risk metric package um and we use that
as well for our internal um risk
assessments and then the environment
itself like the workbench and the
package manager we've had some people
from um it help to bring it up to like a
GXP validated environment that we can
actually run trials in
um yeah I hope that covers it yeah I
think my biggest like issue I've
encountered is just trying to allow any
sort of confidential or patient
sensitive data into a GitHub or even if
it's a private repo or something to to
allow that to be moved out of some
firewalled locked State and so then
comes the question of you know you know
SVN or what do you use at a local level
to to ensure that contain like Docker or
you know kubernetes or what to
containerize the versioning as well as
the validation of the packages and
everything so that it can be built from
that and then it just becomes it just
turns into this mess of trying to uh
explain and and keep separate so if that
makes sense yeah I mean so maybe luckily
I can say I mean we we don't use GitHub
so we have asadov within the Fireball
and I think one of our recent like GSP
GXP requirements are that basically any
system that you're like interacting with
when you're doing trial has to be within
the
firewall um and like in terms of this
system um so of course there's a lot of
documentation for the system that you
need to have in place if somebody were
to kind of inspect the system and our
system will soon I think actually
tomorrow shift to run on kubernetes it's
been running
on like Amazon virtual machines I think
for now um and everything there is built
uh like infrastructure as code so we
have control over everything we do there
and as I mentioned like the the guys
from it are really ones helping uh like
with the requirements around standing up
that environment and they also have like
inspection experience from other systems
that we have so that's been a a huge
help in in kind of getting it to to work
for
us no that's great I yeah thank you oh
sorry
Jared sorry if I cut you off but thank
you so much everybody for for joining
today and and thank you Ari for sharing
your experience with us I I wanted to
remind everybody before you log off if
you want to hear more about the work
they're doing at Nova Nordisk and seei
again presenting uh that event will be
on September 12th and I see Tyler just
shared the link in the chat right now if
you want to check it out um but AR thank
you so much for joining us today yeah
thank you so much for having me it's
it's been an honor to be here yeah if
people want to get connected with you is
is the best way
LinkedIn yeah probably on LinkedIn okay
awesome well thank you all have a great
rest of the day nice to see you bye
everybody
bye